hace unos días todo parece indicar que
andrei baby tendría una reelección
plácida como primer ministro de
república checa este magnate populista
encabezaba con mayoría absoluta todas
las encuestas el conocido como donald
trump centroeuropeo gozaba de
popularidad por su discurso anti
corrupción y anti inmigración
pero los pandora papers se cruzaron en
su camino e hicieron tambalear su
carrera algo que le ha cerrado las
puertas a posibles coaliciones
estoy convencido de que no se puede
lograr un cambio trabajando junto a
quienes crearon estos problemas de leyva
visto por masa del partido populista de
ba bis no es una opción para nosotros
que extremos davis movió hasta 22
millones de euros en cuentas offshore
desde 2009 y compró varias propiedades
de lujo con ese dinero por lo que su
principal discurso político que lo llevó
al poder el de terminar con el
establecimiento corrupto se dinamitó
aunque sigue por delante en las
encuestas su imagen se ha visto muy
dañada y los indecisos han aumentado
con el voto quizá ponga a final al
gobierno y podremos volver a una
situación normal
el próximo gobierno debe ser menos
caótico
creo que nos merecemos más orden y menos
corrupción estaré
tras la salida de los pandora paper el
silencio ha sido la tónica general de
bab y en estos últimos días de campaña
en los que la oposición está intentando
tejer alianzas que tumben al
controvertido mandatario